wir alle befinden uns ja gerade so im
Sparmodus wir schauen wie wir weniger
Geld ausgeben oder andersrum wie wir
möglichst schnell an Geld kommen können
und da werden einige doch sehr kreativ
träumen Sie nicht auch davon an einem
kleinen Bächlein zu sitzen Schale für
Schale Steine und Sand aus dem Flussbett
durch zu sieben und plötzlich der
glitzern sie in der Sonne kleine
Stückchen Gold das passiert hier im Gold
country Kalifornien und Nevada fast
täglich immer mehr Menschen suchen an
den Ufern ihr Glück
Bryant ist hauptberuflich Goldsucher er
berät Anfänger und kann uns von so
manchem Fund berichten
vor fünf Jahren kam hier ein Anfänger
her er hat die Ausrüstung gekauft und
fand auf Anhieb ein 680 Gramm Stück ich
konnte es nicht glauben es hatte die
Größe einer Zigarettenschachtel Bryant
hat die Goldsuche von seinem Vater
gelernt die Sucht nach dem Edelmetall
liegt den Menschen hier in den Genen
1848 bricht hier im Gold country der
Goldrausch aus 300 Goldsucher aus aller
Welt wollen den ganz großen Fund machen
darunter auch viele deutsche sie gründen
1897 Berlin Nevada in Berlin leben zu
Hochzeiten 250 Menschen sie arbeiten
alle in einer Goldmine das Städtchen hat
mehrere Wohnhäuser Geschäfte eine Post
und ein Bordell eine Kneipe sucht man
damals aber vergeblich in der Stadt der
deutschen Alkohol wird vom Eigentümer
der Mine verboten weil Berlin nicht
genug Gold fördert wird die Mine
geschlossen die Stadt stirbt und ist
heute eine der bekanntesten
Geisterstädte Amerikas Gold wird heute
so gefördert industriell Computer
gestützt und tief unter der Erde oder im
Tagebau wir besuchen die Nevada Gold
Mainz es ist der weltweit produktivste
goldminenkomplex mit über 93 Tonnen Gold
pro Jahr das sind 70 Kilogramm Gold
guten Tag und der Markt dafür wird immer
größer
Technologien die Gold benötigen
entwickeln sich immer weiter wir sehen
das Gold in Prozessoren und komplexen
computerschaltkreisen benötigt wird das
vergrößert den Markt
damit solch eine Ausbeute erzielt werden
kann müssen riesige Mengen Gestein
zermahlen mit Chemikalien und
Kohlenstoff bearbeitet werden
bis zu 90 Tonnen Gestein werden für die
Gewinnung von ca 28 Gramm Gold benötigt
um die Umweltzerstörung zu kompensieren
wird das abgepumpte Grundwasser
wenigstens den Farmern der Region zur
Verfügung gestellt in trockenen Nevada
ist das für die Bauern oft wertvoller
als Gold
wir müssen unseren Tagebau und unsere
unterirdischen Minen trockenpumpen
dieses Grundwasser wird getestet um eine
gefährliche Belastung mit Chemikalien
auszuschließen und ein Teil dieses
Wassers können die Bauern der Region
nutzen zurück an den kleinen Bach im
Gold country hier sind sie zu finden die
Glücksritter die ihrer goldsucht Folgen
immer in der Hoffnung auf Goldstaub wie
diesen
sehen Sie hier über 2800 Euro
es ist als ob ich einmal den Jackpot im
Spielcasino geknackt hätte ich komme
immer und immer wieder wenn Sie sich
jetzt auf die Goldsuche machen wollen
hier müssen sie suchen
[Musik]
sie haben die massiven Feuer in
Kalifornien und anderen Bundesstaaten
gesehen diese haben die Böden freigelegt
und jetzt erodieren die Böden und es
kommen Lawinen und es werden neue
Goldvorkommen freigelegt ich glaube
ehrlich der größte Fund ist noch nicht
gefunden worden
der große Goldfund ist also noch
irgendwo hier draußen und er wartet
vielleicht genau auf Sie
[Musik]